So yeah.
By early December,
1914 the punishing advance of the Germans had been stopped by the allies before
the Germans made it to Paris,
but it had been stopped at a great cost,
a sickening cost.
Okay.
The now the armies had settled into the trenches
and we know what the trenches were.
Hell,
not some metaphorical approximation of hell,
but actual hell,
hell on earth,
artillery,
mortars,
machine,
gun,
fire,
snipers,
shrapnel screams of the wounded and dying.
And on top of that,
the environment,
rain and sleet and snow and flooded trenches and freezing cold
Britain.
Of course,
death was everywhere,
everywhere.
And there seemed no end to the horror.
But on Christmas Day,
1914 the whole or did stop if only for a short time,
while men for a moment
recognized the men they were fighting against has other men
as other men with the same hopes and dreams and desires that they had
themselves.
And the chief of all hope
where's piece?
And this is an excerpt
of how the Christmas truce unfolded.
According to Henry Williamson,
the British army officer who is there
parent,
here's what he wrote.
For weeks.
We had lived in flooded trenches.
The Germans were 80 yards away.
Our trench was and fileted.
We lost many men shot by snipers
night after.
Since
the tailing off of the battle of eep res,
we had toiled in the pair of pits,
filling sand bag with clay mud,
squelched through muddy lagoons of woodland tracks,
carrying rations,
duck boards,
pumps and ammunition.
We were volunteers,
rushed out to help general French's shattered expeditionary force.
A few weeks before
we had been schoolboys bank clerks,
undergraduates,
medical students.
Now our lives were ravaged.
Some of us,
the young ones who thought of their mothers were near to despair.
We were without hope,
without horizon.
At first trench life had been interesting,
even enjoyable.
It was fun cooking our own Bacon and making tea in the wood wall.
Shrapnel cracked overhead.
Good sports stalking the wild geese in the marshes.
Satisfying to feel the soft hairs of our unshaven chins.
The regulars were decent Japs heroes of Mons,
but the rains fell
and the trenches filled almost waist high.
After a few days,
we could scarcely move our legs,
nor did we seem to need food
at night.
We dragged ourselves out of the ditches and moved about uncaring of bullets
aimed at random in the dark.
All night we worked carrying parties,
pumping fatigues parapet building at dawn.
We slid into water again and set ourselves to endure the gray daylight.
Even now,
so long afterwards when I hear rain on the tiles overhead,
the ghost of that time makes me draw the blankets closer around my neck.
Okay.
On Christmas Eve of 1914 we were in the support line about 200 yards inside the
plug stick would,
it was freezing
are overcoats where as stiff as boards,
our boots were too hard to move,
but we rejoiced as the mud was hard too.
Also happy thought we would be able to sleep that night
inside a new block house of oak boughs and sand bags called Piccadilly hotel.
No bed but the cold earth,
no blankets even,
but sleep,
sleep.
Then came a message from brigade headquarters broad,
I think by second lieutenant Bruce Baron's father of the Warrick's wiring
parties were required in no man's land all night
and there would be a moon.
We would have to work only 50 yards from the German machine guns in the White
House opposite the eastern edge of the wood.
Two hours later we filed out of the dark trees into the naked moonlit terror of
no man's land holding our shovels besides our faces in hope of protection
against the expected mortar blast,
the moon was high and white among the frozen clouds.
We were visible.
Someone slipped with a click of a spade or rifle.
We flung ourselves on our faces and waited,
but the battlefield was a silent as the moon for an hour.
We worked in silence in a most mysterious soundless snus.
What had happened,
we began to talk naturally as we drove in steaks and pulled out concert teen
have prepared wire.
There was no rifle fire either up or down the line from way up north beyond.
He prays to South Beyond Armand Tyrus and the French army.
At midnight we heard laughing as we worked.
We heard singing from the German lines,
Carol's the tunes of which we knew.
I noticed a very bright light on a tall pole raised in their lines down opposite
the east Lancs trench in front of the convent.
A Christmas tree with lighted candles was set on their pair of Pitt,
the unreal moonlight life.
When on happily cries of,
come on over Tommy,
we won't fire it to you.
A dark figure approached me.
Hesitatingly a trap.
I walk towards it with a bumping heart.
Merry Christmas,
English friend.
We shook hands tremulously
then I saw that the light on the pole was the morning star,
the star in the east.
It was Christmas morning.
All Christmas Day.
Gray and khaki figures mingled and talk to no man's land.
Picks in spades rang in the hard ground.
It was strange to stare at the dead.
We had only glimpse stat swiftly from the trenches.
The shallowest graves were dug,
filled,
and set with crosses,
knocked together from lengths of ration,
boxwood marked with indelible pencil for King and country for fodder,
land on free height,
fatherland and freedom.
Freedom,
freedom.
How was this?
We were fighting for freedom and our cause was just,
we were defending Belgium,
civilization.
These fellows in gray,
we're good fellows.
They were strangely
just men like ourselves.
How can we lose the war?
English comrade Har causes just we are ringed with enemies.
The war was thrust on us.
We are defending our parents,
our homes,
our German soil,
almost shaking,
staggering thought that both sides thought they were fighting for the same
cause.
The war was a terrible mistake.
People at home did not know this.
Then the idea came to the young and callow soldier that if only he could tell
them at home what was really happening and if the German soldiers told their
people the truth about us,
the war would be over,
but he hardly dared to think it.
Even to himself.
The next day was quiet and the next weaving hands from the trenches by day
singing and reflected blaze of trench bonfires at night.
It was a lovely time.
On the third afternoon came a message from the Germans.
At midnight our staff officers visit and we must fire our automatic pistol Olan
but we will fire hire nevertheless,
please keep under cover.
At 11:00 PM Berlin midnight,
we saw flashes going away into air
two days later and army order came from Ghq to the effect that men found
fraternizing with the enemy would be court marshaled and if found guilty would
suffer the death penalty.
And again in that place the they relight sword over no man's land at night.
Then bullets cut showers of splinters from trees and sometimes human flesh and
bone.
So hope sank into the mud again
but did not die
despite a withering a new,
as each poor human unit fell in machine gun and mortar blasts and colossal
reverberating rending of the shells of those four years,
the years whose truth seems to be in communicable.
Sometimes as one listens to what people say here in the England,
a generation died for
it seems like almost pre war again.
Can it be that we lack imagination
to see the other fellow
as ourselves
and Henry Williamson
continued to fight.
He was eventually wounded by gas than when he was declared unfit to serve in the
army.
He then volunteered for the air force to see if that could get him back to the
front.
But he didn't make it back to the front.
Luckily,
because the war ended,
the war ended,
but not before 20 million were wounded and 17 million men were killed.
Men,
just normal men
gone.
Yeah.
So this holiday season,
please
think of those men and women around the world in the trenches now risking life
and limb for what they believe in
for freedom.
And think of the civilians trapped in those hellish places suffering
in the merciless path of war.
And finally,
as Henry Williamson asked,
let us not lack the imagination to think,
to think of other men
as men,
men like ourselves,
men like
us.
Merry Christmas to all.
And may there be peace
on earth.